wir kommunizieren miteinander über
tausende kilometer hinweg sehen dinge
die für unser natürliches auge
unsichtbar sind und können millionen
berechnungen per knopfdruck durchführen
technologien ermöglichen uns einen immer
weiteren blick über unsere biologischen
grenzen hinaus und dieser technologische
fortschritt wird anscheinend auch noch
immer schneller von nur einigen wenigen
jahrzehnten waren smartphone internet
und co noch völlig fremde begriff war
dabei sind sie heute aus unserem alltag
kaum noch wegzudenken
er wird uns dieser fortschritt in den
nächsten jahren und jahrzehnten
hinführen
heute stelle ich euch einen der
vielversprechendsten bereiche vor die
quantentechnologie
[Musik]
die verrückte welt der quantenmechanik
haben wir bereits im letzten video
besprochen
heute werden wir auf dieses grundwissen
aufbauen und uns anschauen inwiefern
diese erkenntnisse für uns technologisch
nützlich sein können wenn du das erste
video also noch nicht gesehen hast dann
findest du entweder hier oder unten in
der video beschreibung einen link dazu
ok wie kann man sich das jetzt also
vorstellen
inwiefern soll dann etwas so
unsichtbares und klein ist wie die
quantenmechanik relevant für alltägliche
geräte sein
die antwort liegt in einem generellen
trend den man in der entwicklung vieler
technologien beobachten kann
während die meisten konzepte oft als
große gläubiger prototypen anfang wenn
sie nach einigen jahren forschung und
entwicklung oft zu kleinen handlichen
und effizienten versionen der
ursprünglichen idee wo früher eine
glühbirne benutzt wurde reichen heute
einige kleine leds
obwohl früher ein computer ein ganzes
zimmer füllte können wir jetzt ein viel
besseres modell in unserer hosentasche
herumtragen und die ersten mikrofone
können qualitativ nicht mit heutigen
anstieg mikros mithalten
je kleiner die bestandteile einer
technologie werden umso näher rücken sie
auch den gesetzen der quantenmechanik
die quantenmechanik gilt schließlich für
den atomaren raum das heißt sobald eine
komponente nur noch aus einigen
molekülen oder atomen besteht werden
kenntnisse der quantenmechanik für die
funktionsweise der technologie
unverzichtbar dabei ist diese
vorstellung gar nicht mehr so neu eine
der wichtigsten erfindungen unserer zeit
ist der transistor eine technologie ohne
die unsere moderne welt gar nicht
denkbar wäre
wahrscheinlich hat jeder von euch schon
mal vom nischen- gesetz gehört der
beobachtung dass sich die anzahl der
transistoren auf einem computer chip
grob alle zwei jahre verdoppelt
genau dieser trend ist mittlerweile nur
noch durch unsere kenntnisse der
quantenmechanik möglich denn ein
einzelner transistor besteht langsam
aber sicher aus nicht viel mehr als
einen kleinen haufen atome wie sonst
sollen denn auch 18 milliarden
transistoren auf vier quadratzentimeter
passe diese aber auch andere
technologien wie zb der laser beruhen
alle auf der quantenmechanik
sie machen zwar nicht aktiv von den
quanteneffekte gebrauch unterliegen aber
trotzdem ihren gesetzen eine tatsache
die also beispielsweise bei der
konstruktion moderner computerchips
beachtet werden muss so einflussreich
die computertechnik aber auch bisher war
wir haben wahrscheinlich gerade einmal
die spitze des eisbergs gesehen denn uns
steht eine quanten revolution bevor und
mit ihr erwarten uns technologien die
alle möglichen branchen grundlegend
verändern könnten
im gegensatz zum heutigen mikrochip bei
denen uns die quantenmechanik begrenzt
werden wir dieses mal aktiv gebrauch von
ihren quanteneffekte machen
eine der grundlegendsten methoden zur
entschlüsselung unseres universums ist
die erfassung physikalischer größen
geschwindigkeit volumen zeit distanz
fast alles um uns herum kann gemessen
werden die messungen bildet die
grundlage der wissenschaft an sich es
ist also auch nur logisch dass wir
versuchen unsere technologien zu
verbessern um eventuell noch mehr über
die naturgesetze herauszufinden
genau hier eröffnet uns vor allem ein
quanten effekt neue bisher unerreichte
möglichkeiten die super position im
letzten video habe ich ja bereits
erwähnt die quantenteilchen mehrere
zustände gleichzeitig annehmen können
diese überlagerung zustände kollabieren
sobald etwas mit ihnen interagiert und
genau diese tatsache könnte sich für die
sensorik als sehr hilfreich erweisen
quantenteilchen reagieren wegen dieses
effekts nämlich auf die kleinsten
variationen in ihrem umfeld setzt eine
minimale änderung der gravitation durch
zum beispiel ein objekt in der nähe kann
eine messbare schwankungen der
überlagerungszustand auslösen
eine solche schwankungen kann man sich
am besten als eine temporäre
entscheidung des teilchens für einen der
zustände vorstellen
je nach stärke dieser schwankungen
können wir dann rückschlüsse auf den
eigentlichen messwert ziehen
mit hilfe der sensibilität von
quantenteilchen können wir also sehr
genaue sensoren bauen
wenn wir es schaffen quanteneffekte in
der sensorik aktiv zu nutzen könnten wir
nicht nur normale größen wie zeit
beschleunigung und rotation flügen auer
messen sondern auch komplizierte
messungen von magnetischen elektrischen
oder gravitations feldern verbessern
bereits bekannte kommerzielle beispiele
die von quantenmechanischen
fortschritten dieser art gebrauch machen
könnten während die atomuhr und das gps
so ein quanten gps könnt ihr nämlich
circa 1000 mal genauer sein als unser
bisheriges verfahren in der zukunft
werden solche sensoren aber noch viel
tiefgreifendere implikationen mit sich
bringen laut tk einer deutschen
initiative zur förderung von quanten
technologien sind zum beispiel größere
durchbrüche in der erdbeobachtung und
erkundung als auch der
grundlagenforschung der physik zu
erwarten
letztendlich könnten wir damit also
sonst auf schätzwerten basierende
größten wie zum beispiel den umfang der
erde ziemlich präzise bestimmen oder
auch einfach nur eine viel genauere
wettervorhersage erreichen
auch die datensicherheit könnte von den
quanten technologien profitieren
sie ist immerhin ein thema das mit dem
aufkommen unserer vernetzten welt nicht
mehr wegzudenken ist denn so etabliert
ist mittlerweile auch sein mag das
internet steckt in manchen aspekten
immer noch in den kinderschuhen
zurzeit werden nämlich viele unserer
informationen und sicher übermittelt
die informationen werden verschlüsselt
und nur die beteiligten geräte der
verbindung haben auf den so genannten
privaten schlüssel zugriff man benötigt
also diesen schlüssel um zum beispiel
die nachrichten von einer anderen person
zu lesen
außenstehende die unerlaubt an daten
herankommen wollen müssen also den
entsprechenden schlüssel erst berechnen
um zb deine whatsapp chats lesen zu
können
und das dauert lange oder genau hier
liegt das problem dieses prinzip der
datensicherheit basiert auf der annahme
dass der außenstehende nicht genug
rechenleistung hat um den schlüssel in
einem praktikablen zeitraum wenn
überhaupt zu berechnen nur werden unsere
computer wie bereits erwähnt immer
besser und mit dem aufkommen der
quantencomputer einem thema auf dass wir
gleich noch einmal zurückkommen werden
wäre tägliche algorithmische
verschlüsselung völlig sinnlos denn mit
ihnen können vor allem komplexe
mathematische aufgaben wie zum beispiel
die entzifferung eines schlüssels
millionenfach schneller bewältigt werden
wie können wir also datenklau in der
zukunft verhindern was die quanten in
der digitalen welt gefährden können sie
auch schützen
die sogenannte quantenkommunikation und
kryptographie könnt ihr die lösung für
dieses aber auch für zukünftige probleme
der datensicherheit seien die
überlegungen kann man sich wie folgt
veranschaulichen so veraltet die idee
eines briefs auch sein mag die normale
post hat einen vorteil man muss den
brief öffnen um ihn zu lesen
dagegen ist unsere momentane digitale
kommunikation wie ein offenes buch einen
datenklau bleibt auch unbemerkt bis es
eventuell zu spät ist
man kann nicht sehen ob jemand anderes
zb seine e mails gelesen hat und genau
das will man mit der
quantenkommunikation ändern
mit ihr soll das beste aus beiden welten
zusammen finden man wird also sehen
können ob ein digitaler brief geöffnet
wurde
grundsätzlich kann man sich das ganze
übrigens wie ein physikalisches system
anstelle des momentan rein digitalen
verfahrens vorstellen
daten werden hier nämlich über die
zustände der quantenteilchen übertragen
welche wie bereits erwähnt sehr sensibel
gegenüber veränderungen sind jeglicher
lauschangriff würde also eine
nachweisbare zustands änderung in der
leitung hervorrufen
dadurch könnten eingebaute
sicherheitssysteme sofort erkennen ob
auf die informationen unerlaubterweise
zugegriffen wird
der vorteil diese zustands änderungen in
der leitung kann nicht mehr
wiederhergestellt werden
es wäre physikalisch unmöglich kein
wunder also dass die
quantenkommunikation bereits als
mögliche dauerhafte lösung für die
verschlüsselung von daten gesehen wird
aber die wohl spannendste
quantentechnologie kommt noch die
quantencomputer sie sind eine der
aussichtsreichsten konzepte der zukunft
und versprechen rechenleistungen die
jenseits aller momentanen erwartungen
sind bereits die heutigen großen und
klobigen prototypen sind bei bestimmten
aufgaben circa 100 millionen mal
schneller als ein durchschnittlicher pc
ähnlich wie unsere gegenwärtige rechner
profitieren auch die quantencomputer von
einem gewissen technologischen
fortschritt das heißt diese 100
millionen fache leistung könnte in den
nächsten 20 jahren locker im bereich der
millionenfachen rechenleistung landen
aber wieso sind quantencomputer so
schnell und wodurch unterscheiden sie
sich von unseren heutigen pcs
das sind fragen denen wir uns im
nächsten video annehmen werden im
dritten teil dieser quanten serie die
ich für das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung produziere stelle
ich euch nämlich die welt der quanten
komplikationen genauer vor
obwohl wir also schon so weit gekommen
sind stehen wir erst in den anfängen
einer welt in der technologie wahre
wunder bewirken kann
durch diese ansicht auf unsere zukunft
gewinnen die berühmten worte von afri
ski klagt er ist wirklich an bedeutung
jede hinreichen fortschrittliche
technologie ist von magie nicht zu
unterscheiden
denn selbst für viele leute die heute
leben könnten diese neuen möglichkeiten
schon fast an magie grenzen quanten
technologien werden uns wahrscheinlich
viele lang ersehnte antworten zu den
großen fragen unseres universums geben
aber gleichzeitig auch so viele neue
fragen aufwerfen wer weiß
heutige probleme könnten morgen
vielleicht schon beinahe lachhaft
erscheinen die zukunft wird also
spannend
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]